you task yourself with in order to yield
that result
Ed you know I play together you know we
said in the ball and I play a defense
together Rory thank you so much thank
you guys back to you
all right we have a whistle and a foul
gonna go against the Grizzlies LeBron
James shaken up and they're going to
review it at the official scores table
[Applause]
LeBron hit in the lower this foul will
be received for the appropriate penalty
foul is going to go again still in
Brooks
it's going to be reviewed
on the opening sequence Memphis turned
it over which gave the ball
to the Lakers there's a look at it
Brooks on the reach
connecting with LeBron's midsection
there it is right there with the left
arm this will be fascinating
because it is in very recent memory
we've seen Draymond Green adjudicated
for his history
and Dylan Brooks led the league with 18
technical fouls obviously led to a
suspension in the course of the regular
season that looks like a direct shot
[Applause]
Ron finally up but you have a great
Point Doris it's not a stand-alone
eventually then obviously
you know different plays in terms of
[Applause]
shoot a flavorful too it has been
ejected from the game wow
remember the play on James Harden so
Draymond obviously different style play
the foul on James Harden was so similar
to that but that's flagrant and
unnecessary
Taylor Jenkins having a conversation
with Mark Davis they obviously disagree
the foul was made
and the whistle blew immediately be very
indecisive yeah very interested as you
see Dylan Brooks make his way back his
night is over three of 13 from the field
seven points and two rebounds second
career ejection for
[Applause]
second career rejection for Dylan Brooks
James will have a couple of free throws
[Applause]
James had 12 in the first half for the
Lakers knocks down the second let's
bring in Kane Fitzgerald can't explain
the process of this call being evaluated
arriving at flagrant penalty two
sure look at the contact and it's direct
contact to the groin the contacts are
necessary and it's it's a real good shot
to the groin area so which makes it
excessive as well that leads you to the
flag of penalty too any uh with Dylan
Brooks obviously one career objection
[Music]
come into play at all or
exclusively based on the visual there no
not at all it's just exclusively based
on this play and the contact and where
it occurred directly to the groin
all right thanks a lot King no problem
by the way the lead is down to 14 now